southbound on taxes it'll be three male
blacks the vehicles the white Hyundai I
believe at any time during this evening
did it go through your mind that this
was not a human being that you were
beating the police approached black men
as criminals first and citizens second
most our children that for African
American children an adult freedom is
not yet a reality in the United States
if they cannot get a conviction with the
Rodney King video available that can be
no justice in America we the jury find
the defendant not guilty
today this jury told the world that what
we all saw wasn't a crime
[Applause]
this show Los Angeles that we are
resilient there's been a mini riot is
this location
to be a human being
[Applause]
they're pulling the driver out there
eating the driver oh my god
how much worse doesn't need to get
proclamation of the state of emergency
for a Los Angeles City we have no police
support whatsoever
[Music]
all right I will use whatever force is
necessary to restore order
[Music]
folks you're on your own down there